in nearly every corner of the earth ants
wage war against each other
their weapons are what nature gave them
some have strong
armor deadly stingers or sharp mandibles
and then there's this tiny and not very
impressive ant
but it rules the biggest empire any ant
has ever built
economies spanning continents and
fighting wars that leave
millions of casualties let's take a look
at this
unlikely warrior s lynn epithelma
the argentine ant
[Music]
this story begins in the floodplains
around the paranal river
in south america it's a crowded ant
megalopolis
where dozens of ant species fight for
dominance including
fire ants army ants and the rather an
impressive
argentine ant it measures only two to
three millimeters in length
and with its small mandibles it's
surprising that it survived among its
buff competitors
their homes are equally unremarkable
their colonies range from fairly small
to very large
and can be found anywhere under logs in
loose leaf litter or the former colonies
of other ants
here argentine ants prepare their most
effective weapon against their
competitors
bodies most ant species have only one
queen to produce ants
while argentine ants went all in on
numbers
for every 120 workers there's one queen
laying up to 60 eggs a day so their
colonies grow
fast and have millions or billions of
individuals
teams of queens and workers frequently
branch out
and found new colonies but this strategy
has a downside
as colonies grow and produce a lot of
offspring mutations occur
and new colonies adapt to new
environments their dna slowly changes
from generation to generation
and differences accumulate so after a
while
the ants that left the colony will
become more like distant cousins
and start to compete with their mother
colony
in their native south american range
this is how argentine ants behave
within their colonies they are very
cooperative and well organized
but they fight vicious wars against
other argentine and colonies
and other ant species with equally
strong opponents on every side
the argentine ant became extremely
aggressive
fighting for every inch of ground but it
could never dominate its neighbours
until humans showed up we did what
humans do
and transported things around the world
by ship on one of them
a few argentine ant queens hitched a
ride as stowaways from south america to
madeira
and new orleans the argentine ants
suddenly found themselves in a strange
world instead of being surrounded by
deadly enemies
they found only victims nobody could
fight them effectively
because only a few argentine and queens
were introduced to the outside world
the resulting colonies had very low
genetic diversity
on top of that the introduced argentine
ants kill up to 90 percent of their
queens every year
fewer queens less genetic variation
so as these colonies spread across the
landscape ants that left the colony
were no longer considered distant
cousins as a result
the new colonies form not opposing
but cooperating parties called super
colonies
this is a very uncommon strategy in the
ant kingdom
only a few of the sixteen thousand ant
species have evolved super colonies a
super colony was established on the west
coast of the usa
and became a base for the tiny ants
global conquest
today the argentine ant inhabits the
mediterranean zones of six continents
and many islands this one super colony
was especially successful
establishing sister locations in
california europe
japan new zealand and australia forming
one
massive intercontinental mega colony of
argentine ants
this makes them the largest society on
earth more numerous than even the human
one
but their success has changed the
ecosystems they invaded
california is a perfect example of this
in their greed for more territory the
invading argentine ants have
overrun and replaced 90 percent of the
native ant species
including several species of californian
carpenter ants
although carpenter ant workers are
giants their colonies have
only between three thousand and six
thousand individuals
and stand no chance against an expanding
super colony of billions of argentine
ants
argentine and workers attack by wiping
toxic chemicals on their victims
which irritates the enemy and marks them
as a target for
other argentine ants when they attack
the argentine ants
wash over their victims clinging on to
their opponents in groups
and pulling apart their limbs it doesn't
matter how many of them die
there are always more once the colony is
overrun and exterminated
the argentine ants feed on their victims
brood and take over their home and
territory
the argentine ants numbers allow them to
hunt down and devour such an excessive
mass of different insects
that over time some species disappear
from the ants territory completely
argentine ants don't care about working
with the local flora and fauna
they consume them and move on and
if their next stop happens to be human
property they will rudely make
themselves at home there too
they forage in dumpsters bowls of pet
food and
sneak into kitchens to claim leftovers
not just
our homes our gardens and fields are
also impacted by argentine ants
since they tend to hordes of aphids as
their cattle
the aphids feed from plants and produce
a sweet honeydew which they trade with
the ants for protection
since the ants have no major enemy to
fear in their new homes
the aphids thrive and ultimately kill
the plants they live on
so on top of being a major disruption
for the ecosystems they invade
they are also a huge pest for
agriculture
but the rule of the argentine ant is
being challenged
parts of the super colonies have broken
off and become their own empires
a merciless civil war has broken out
for example the lake hodges super colony
has been fighting against the very large
colony for years in san diego county
a massive war is going on over a dynamic
front line
stretching over kilometers an estimated
30 million ants die here each year
on other fronts an old acquaintance from
the parana river has risen from the
shadows
red imported fire ants which were
accidentally introduced from their old
home
to the coast of alabama not only are the
red fire ants fierce
fighters and more than able to deal with
the argentine ant they are also able to
form
super colonies themselves now the old
wars from their distant home
have been taken to a foreign
battleground
in the south eastern the super colonies
clashed fiercely
the argentine ants found themselves
outgunned by the fire ants
the fire ants major workers are more
than twice the size of the argentine
ends and wheeled venom injecting
stingers
even though the argentine ants fought
fiercely the fire rents were too much
for them
after countless lost battles the red
imported fire ant exterminated the
argentine ants super colony from much of
the south eastern u.s
this is one territory lost but the
argentine ants will fight on
this amazing network of cooperating
super colonies
is the biggest success in their history
and they'll not give it up because of a
small defeat
they will stand their ground against any
enemy that might arise
no matter if it's on the parana river or
on one of the large battlefields across
the world
these videos were developed with the
support of curiositystream
a subscription streaming service with
thousands of documentaries and
non-fiction titles
quartzkazak viewers can visit
curiositystream.com to get a free 31 day
trial
to watch films like big world in a small
garden a documentary that takes a close
look at the world of insects around us
or other documentaries by the likes of
stephen hawking dave attenborough and
many more
all available for offline viewing once
your trial is over the subscription is
only 2.99 a month
curiosity stream was founded by the same
people who started the discovery channel
with documentaries spanning science
nature history technology and lifestyle
it's a great way to binge watch fun
videos while accidentally learning
things
thank you so much to our friends at
curiositystream for supporting
our end succession and making ambitious
projects like this possible
stay tuned for part three and visit
curiositystream curiositystream.com
for your free trial